hey guys my name is Jenna welcome to
episode 113 of game programming so last
time yesterday actually we we did the
sprite rotation thing where we first of
all cover the algorithm which is right
over here
get including these two methods over
here and and we figured out a way to
make these arrows actually rotate as you
can see the sprite is rotating towards
the direction in which it is going now
the problem that we faced was
performance basically so you can see the
frame rate dropping over here all the
way down like 60 and if we check if we
take a look at this let me quickly make
the console just to touch bigger here so
that you guys can see it where are we
debug console formless but then it's
like 18 okay there we go you can see
that it's running at around a million
times per second okay now that's a lot
so what we want to do is not necessarily
do that right we want to be able to say
that you know what sprites don't have to
be rotated every time yeah once it's got
its direction it's done the same sprite
will be used okay it'll continue going
until the sprite gets destroyed until
the entity which is the projectile gets
destroyed and that's the end of that
okay so that it's not there's not gonna
be a need to rotate it again now I did
read the comments from yesterday's video
okay from us from episode 112 you guys
did say what if it like tracks at all or
if we still wanted to rotate that's fine
right you guys know how to implement
that yourselves I'm not gonna bother
with that until we unless we you know
get up to a point in the game where it's
necessary but the idea is that if that's
the case still it does not need to get
rotated this many times per second okay
you can make it track and this new
system will also work with that as well
so don't worry okay anyway so let's take
this rotate method and think about how
we can reduce the amount of time it's
going to be called so first off let's
get rid of this rotate plus plus thing
and in game as well because we don't
need to track the amount of times it
actually does get run anymore that was
you know old school stuff that was just
a test what we are going to do though is
actually move this stuff into the sprite
class
okay so right now I did it in screen
just to get it up just to get it up and
running right just to make sure it works
and to get it working with the I guess
the least amount of abstraction writing
really put it into multiple classes and
split it up because that way it would be
harder for you guys to actually dissect
it and learn how about how it works so
that's why I put it here but we're
actually going to take it away and put
it into into something else okay so
we're gonna put into the sprite class
okay why because the things were
rotating our sprites okay it's gonna be
actually really simple well then just
grab this private int rotate okay along
with this double rotation you know X and
rotation y methods okay we're gonna cut
that control X on Windows in case you
guys don't know
and then in sprite okay right under
let's just have a constructor we've got
the split method we're gonna just paste
it in here okay that should give us no
errors and then what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna make I'm not gonna make a
constructor okay I could but I'm not
going to what I will do is just make a
static method that returns sprite I'll
call it rotate okay and let's see so
it'll take in first of all an existing
sprite yeah so the sprite that we want
to rotate and it'll also take in the
angle and which you want to rotate it to
all right and then all we're gonna do
yeah all we're gonna do is return yeah a
new sprite that is consistent of rotate
the rotate method right the sprite that
we're going to be rotating of course is
ordinal --this probably gonna be
rotating but this pixels array that
we're actually going to be rotating will
be let's see
it'll be sprite dot pixels okay the
width and height will be sprite with
sprite dot height we can't use all these
private map private fields because
obviously we are in this black class in
which these fields declared and also the
angle will just be the angle which is up
here
okay so we're grabbing that and then we
need the width and height so a sprite
width and this is for the constructor of
sprite by the way we're out of the
rotate method obviously and I'll go
through this is a second surprise it
with this fragile high and that should
be it okay so rotate let's see so you
got we
pixels we got with and we gonna heighten
and we got angle so that should be fine
okay we need to make a static that's
right okay and obviously we need to make
these two static as well which shouldn't
be a problem because obviously they're
not going to use any fields anyway so
there we go okay everything's nice and
done now so let's go through this
quickly so we've got a sprite
constructor up here which takes in a
pixel array okay width and height and
create a sprite out of these pixels
because what a sprite really is
fundamentally is an array of pixels and
a bunch of metadata it just to you know
describe that array but essentially it's
an array of pixels okay
now that's the way that works okay so
what we can do is we can say you know
what let's take in our rotation basis
because rotate does return an array of
pixels okay we've got our width we call
that height we got an angle and then we
obviously need sprite width and height
to complete this constructor okay and
that's it okay so that's all we're doing
and we're copying these pixels across as
you can see okay even though that wasn't
really unnecessary because it's does
create a new alright
it doesn't matter it'll work okay that's
that done so what can we do now well
first of all I'm going to get rid of
this render projectile method which
takes an angle okay I'll just get rid of
that completely we don't need that
anymore that was just for dancing
purposes and within with the projectile
go I'll get rid of angle and all I have
to do now is say that this sprite
instead of being equal to sprite or
projectile arrow it'll be equal to
sprite don't rotate okay so this drive
will rotate is the original projectile
arrow and the angle will just be the
angle all right and that's that okay so
that's what we're setting sprite to so
now if I were to run this okay and we
check we take a look look at that okay
work exactly the same way as it did
before except you can see the frame rate
over here does not drop to 60 it drops
to about 2500 okay and you can see
they're constantly firing okay so it's
pretty fast much faster than was before
so there we go that's essentially the
end of the episode if you guys have any
questions or whatever let me know this
method what I did mention before
actually was the fact that
if you wanted to rotate multiple times
or for some reason you just want it to
follow you wanted to track something and
does rotate based on trajectory or
there's all there's all these different
ideas that you guys might have you can
still do that all right
all you have to do okay all you have to
do is somewhere in the update method
just go sprite rotate the current sprite
which can either be sprite if you want
to rotate it based on the current sprite
okay which will be the already rotated
one or you can actually go back to the
original sprite which is projectile
arrow and rotate that and then of course
you can rotate it I don't know why
you're doing pace on the fire rate but
you can rotate it on a custom angle okay
doesn't really matter okay
so for example yet to demonstrate this
what you could do is say something like
this if we wanted it to be rotated we
could have a private int time we'll set
that equal to zero although time plus
plus yeah we can say that if time so
maybe like once or maybe not once maybe
um
what a nice let's just say like 10 times
per second so we'll say time on six
equals zero right that will occur for
six times per second ten times per
second sorry so what we'll do here is
we'll say probably just said sprite a
called a sprite don't rotate so sprite
our originals prior maybe the angle will
be something like math dot pi divided by
I don't know something small let's just
say it like to go about 20 all right all
right there yeah so if we do something
like that and we take a look at this now
you can see the arrow is being rotated
okay it looks kind of like a boomerang
but we're still running pretty fast okay
we're still running quite fast if I go
down here and it's being rotated all
throughout here you can see that it's
performance is still very very good okay
in fact it's even higher than what the
for for some reason but the point is
it's around twenty-five hundred frames
it's fine to play seven hundred even
okay and it's being rotated that seems
like a bit too much we can make it
happen a lot quicker or more often that
might look better he can see Oh looks
pretty weird actually kind of cool
though okay so you can play around with
you can see the performance is fine all
right so don't be afraid of that you can
still dynamically rotate it it's just
that there's no need to do with that
often okay
so yeah that's gonna wrap up the episode
if you guys have any questions just
leave a comment below I'll try and reply
to as many comments as I can and be sure
to like the video as well if you enjoyed
it that always just helps me make sure
that I'm making good videos and yeah
I'll see you guys next I don't know what
we'll do next time so if you guys that's
another thing I don't know what what
we'll do next time so if you guys want
to drop any suggestions down below in
the comments that would be much
appreciated and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you